تقول الديمقراطية: لا تسكت
الناس، لا تخنق الناس،
لا تغلق ميكروفوناتهم عندما
يتحدثون عن أهمية
قضية الحياة التي تعود إلى هذه القضايا الثلاثة هي
أننا بحاجة إلى قادة لديهم الشجاعة
للتصرف
في دور الدولة وفي واشنطن العاصمة
والكونغرس الأمريكي،
لدينا الشجاعة للتصرف
بدلاً من الجبن
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
بالأمس، بدا الأمر وكأنه مسار من عصر جيم كرو
حيث رأينا رجلين أسودين
يقاتلان من أجل حياتهم المهنية يناضلان من أجل
سمعتهما
يناضلان من أجلهما.  حياتهم السياسية
[موسيقى]
نحن بحاجة إليكم جميعًا وقيادتكم في
هذه الحركة ستؤثر على الناس،
وقد لا تقابل أبدًا أشخاصًا قد
لا يعرفون اسمك أبدًا ولكن بسبب
قيادتك سوف يستفيدون إلى الأبد،
هذا يوم تاريخي لتينيسي  لكنه
قد يمثل يومًا مظلمًا جدًا
لتينيسي
لأنه تم إرسال إشارة إلى الأمة
ولكن لا توجد ديمقراطية في هذه الولاية
[موسيقى]